what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here with Cisco Ramon and the flash TV
series we're on and on III 2017 is upon
us every year when it come on this
channel or e3 I have to give a
disclaimer I'm not a gamer everyone
asked me to do all his trailers and I'm
like I'm not a gamer I always tried to
bring on people who actually play video
games consistently and people like Tony
Gill trees on Instagram it's in the
gamer on Twitch he's a regular frequent
gamer he live streams throughout the
week on his twitch now when I've been
doing he's been doing that this guy
pressured me into them but I didn't want
to keep going probably have another
disclaimer that throughout the waste yes
I know there's a lot of trailers that
have already been released and there's
more coming out all my gamer buddies
they all have really tight busy
schedules but I've talked to a lot of
them in text today so they're all coming
over on like separate days so on Monday
Wednesday and then Friday if nothing
comes out at the rate that you want it
to come out that is because I'm working
around everyone else's schedule right
now it's usually in the evenings when
they're available that disclaimer roll
ups will be in the next video
but let's start off with the Dragon Ball
fighters II reveal trailer
all class
[Music]
fighting evil ways
[Music]
and I am
[Music]
yeah make
all right
my generation know it now Iceman you
know I actually do have some thoughts as
much as I said I'm not a gamer I have
some thoughts but I could give you I
like to fight I'm good at I think if
there's one thing I get pretty good at
it's the fighting games I'm pretty damn
good at you know when I read a tonne is
on one let's put on put on one of those
and just do check-in 200 games the
Dragon Ball games as I was the trigger
to sorta I started looking back in when
Dragon Ball Z games were already coming
out like way back in the day yeah they
both were cool so it's always been cool
when you could do the car view like from
the very GetGo they've always been cool
watching the evolution of it it's really
neat because I love the blend with the
like the seeming less blend of
transitioning when you're fighting and
then you like to cut to like the
animation style and because the fighting
mode already looks like the anime when
you're playing you know I come as
comparative like injustice whenever they
do the cutaway extra special combo it
looks like a movie clip and then the
fighting graphics look different here
the fighting graphics and the movie clip
looks fairly similar because it's all
inspired by the anime look yeah I mean
it's the way the movements are just keep
getting crazier and crazier and more
like my favorite parts of the trailer or
whether like a quick dig with uh how I
feel further this one compared to all
the other ones have come out for a while
they've been trying to like for the last
couple games it sound like just be able
to expand your surrounding so like it
says a fight could be far distance away
you have to actually traveled again to
the fireman don't feel like Marvel vs.
Capcom in a little bit oh yeah
you have the three-on-three to knee just
guys no clashing in each other just like
how Marvel vs. Capcom it feels like
they're trying to go away from that like
all you have to go far this is just a
catch-up
yeah try finding one just get back into
the fight even when you did those kicks
from like throwing it into another dish
that might be like transitioning to
another area they had played make it
make it this smells like I was jumping
into like Dragon Ball Z Street Fighter
yeah
and perfect man with the way the other
games were like I enjoyed them it was
way more of like just trying to open
world it in a way but at the end of day
I just want to get back to just some
straight-up drivin and really like but
would a dragon ball game that's all you
really care and I'm all for like story
expansion and honoring the story that's
cutscenes and clips and why not but when
you're playing a Dragonball Z game you
just want to get it for me I'm the kind
of guy who just wants to get to the
fighting like right away all the games
that came out for it it's like you can
only tell the Dragon Ball Z story we all
know so any time just like town this is
just like update is the exact same story
though we get with it over there don't
get a lot different I feel like it would
just be good to go through the story
again like get the old references that
you get from like the old movies that
part of the shows that they have and who
knows they might be able to start
putting in a lot of the new characters
right but the new Dragon Ball super is
now advanced and stuff just to get it
back into just straight fight I don't
are I need a fly for about like one
minute to catch her what it is then yeah
I'm up for this I'm up for this I can't
wait til you buy it so I can play I'm
gonna live streaming right when it comes
out look at e3 games come out like a
year later and stuff so we're gonna get
a lot more trance for this as like get
really in-depth but I'm excited man I
hope it comes out like really soon
let's hope so alright guys well there we
go kicking off the e3 trailer is all
right for you to channel subscribe to
the real reject click that notification
bell
Tony Gill is a tree on Instagram but
more importantly if you don't care look
at his photos make sure to follow him on
twitch at it's in the gamer I
occasionally guess on there I have a
twitch account that I've haven't used to
get off that up and we start figuring
out how to do it just right now I'm not
coming over
more just because if he's doing these
game trails I at least want people to
know that he is trying to get into the
yeah so it's not like he's damn sure is
throwing out information just based off
of a bridge I go actually flame yeah for
show for show for shoka show me all
right take care of her